marco armand is here he's
m-a-r-c-o-a-r-m-e-n-t
on the twitter he's pretty active um and
uh
he uh has a website marco.org
and of course he makes the best
podcasting app and my personal opinion
is the one i use is my daily i'll
i'll use spotify from time to time i'll
use i itunes the apple podcast
but overcast is my default mainly
because i love the queue
and i love the custom settings the queue
to me is everything i just start at the
top of my queue i work my way down and i
have
my paid podcast in one area it's just a
great product damn when you hear
marco talk about hey you know spotify
now has this big chip stack i'm adding
that piece and they're going to take
something like joe rogan which is
i think the number one podcast in the
world and they're gonna say you know
what
it's now uh gonna we're gonna control it
we're gonna control it a hundred percent
maybe there'll be clips here or there
but
no more rss feed it's not gonna be
available on other players it's an
exclusive
whereas when they bought um
bill simmons's company i think for 200
or so 250
they said hey the podcast will almost
all be available still on rss we may
cherry pick some content what do you
think about this change we've only seen
like a couple of examples and then
there's luminary which i think is
failing
um pretty hard actually because
i mean there's so much great content out
there that for me like russell simmons
i'm interested in maybe listening to
russell simmons but i'm not interested
in paying for us so
not russell simmons russell brand yeah i
think that they're
uh they're the one that is the easiest
for everybody to see how that one's
going i think there's probably a lot of
situations like luminary we just don't
know as much about their financials
but agreed but but to get back to the
rogan thing i mean look to me
this is another domino to fall that for
those of us that have been working in
this field for a long time
you know a decade or longer some of us
um
you know it's been getting gentrified
for a while and you know i think to some
extent this is
uh this harkens back to like howard
stern moving from terrestrial radio
to sirius or xm at the time
but i i think it it suggests a general
trend and this really started in 2018
you know the shot across the bow that i
saw was when i heart picked up stuff
media for like 55 million
and then one by one you keep seeing
these things happen now rogan because
he's top dog that one's getting the most
headlines
but i think this is just one in a
succession of many
and unfortunately i think that it is um
unfortunately i think that this is the
new way that this is gonna go you know
this is starbucks
moving into the the hipster town and
everybody goes oh man it's getting so
commercial
it's gonna happen it's gonna ruin some
things that we love about podcast
it's going to open up opportunities as
well and i think what is the opportunity
to open up yeah
uh potentially better uh listener
experiences you know you've got real
horsepower behind
groups like spotify that are that are
coming in and can actually
um you know like how long have people
been uh
complaining about discoverability you
know and recommendations
you know how about navigability being
able to go
you know you can't talk to the thing
right now but and
we may talk about this later in our
conversation here today but you know
think about the opportunity
with connected voice and what's going to
happen
um as that industry keeps emerging and
what real players are going to be able
to do to
evolve the listening experience and
they're also just going to be able to
resource some programs that
is really really hard in kind of the
ragtag way that most of us have come to
love the industry
um so i i think it's both i think
there's a good and a bad but but what
you have to understand is that there's
really two worlds that are starting to
split off here
this place was built by venture
capital-backed startups
you know i was at the beginning and we
launched brands like
dollar shave club um zip recruiter blue
apron me undies these were companies
that came in
and we put them on podcast because
frankly they couldn't afford to do a lot
else other than
you know search and and and that's why
we've had all these
crazy promo codes and vanity urls
uh for for all these reasons because
these are performance marketers they're
counting customers when they buy the ads
now
that's not going to be what gets podcast
to the next level that's what got us
here what gets the
ecosystem to the next level is when they
get brand dollars
so coors light which is the sponsor of
our podcast now and i'm do i'm
popping open a crisp light once in a
while you know what i thought when i saw
it
uh marco and i think i may have
responded to you on twitter about this
is
what i like about this is i think it now
turns
i don't want to see uh you know the top
200 podcasts all get taken off the
market
but if one or two get picked off and
they become platform specific
it's almost like you know issa rae going
from youtube to hbo and having a bigger
budget okay fine
but it opens up another slot because the
number one podcaster is gone
we all get to move up one in the ranking
so as long as it doesn't become
a huge trend if people want to cash out
like howard stern did
and lose you know because i think joe
rogan loses audience in this he's going
to lose audience
so marco what do you think about that as
like a sort of counter and is it
is it okay for people to get
cherry-picked or do you think we're
actually in an existential problem where
what happened with rss and blogs was
twitter i don't think supports rss
anymore
medium doesn't support rss and rss
players all when
all the rss readers went away except for
maybe feedburner
i mean rss there's still a you know
community of nerds like me who use it
every day
but you know certainly it isn't as big
as it used to be and i think that's
largely because the world of blogs isn't
as big as it used to be and that
that has lots of effects or causes to it
um i think you can you can point
directly to social networks and and
timelines being
the way people consume and produce most
information these days
as as probably the biggest reason um but
going back to your question um
i think you know there is some degree of
certainly audience loss like you know
when howard stern moved to sirius
uh he did like i went with him but most
people didn't go
he lost 90 of his audience he went from
20 30 million a day to like two
right and and this is why you know when
when somebody like rogan moves to a
single app
he does have the advantage that spotify
is a big app and
by by most numbers spotify seems to have
something like
10 market share of podcast listening uh
apps
and that's that's a lot you know that's
that's and they they achieve that fairly
quickly so that's not nothing
but that's not the entire market
right and people people know from the
world of video apps like you know if you
want to watch your
tv shows through an app you have to have
17 different apps to watch all the shows
you want to watch because every network
and everything has its own thing
nobody wants that no consumers hate that
nobody would
would accept that if they had much of a
choice and right now podcasting has gone
all this time where the vast majority of
content people listen to
can be accessed in one app and it's even
better
it can be one of like 100 apps but it's
like you can just have one app on your
phone and hear all your podcasts
and so when when one or two podcasts
have
have been purchased and moved to
exclusive deals with somebody
they do lose a lot of audience and we do
like i hear from them from
you know overcast customers i hear from
them from as you know i see people
online complaining to them that they
can't
listen in their podcast app anymore and
the biggest thing i hear is
they mostly stop listening to that to
those shows